duro golpe para kenia después de que el
tribunal internacional de justicia se
pusiera del lado de somalia tras una
prolongada disputa sobre las fronteras
marítimas de los dos países
este veredicto es un muy buen ejemplo de
la transparencia y la apertura de la sej
j kenia debería haber la decisión del
tribunal como una oportunidad para
fortalecer la relación de los dos países
en el centro de la disputa estaba la
delimitación de su frontera marítima
conjunta desde la costa keniana defendía
que su frontera debía discurrir en línea
recta hacia el este pero somalia
insistió en que la frontera debía seguir
la orientación de su frontera terrestre
algo que resultó en un área de 100.000
kilómetros cuadrados en disputa rica
para la pesca y potencialmente en
hidrocarburos el martes los jueces
dictaminaron por unanimidad que no había
una frontera acordada en vigor y
trazaron una nueva cercana a lo que su
mal ya había pedido el tribunal está por
tanto satisfecho con la línea ajustada
que ha establecido como el límite
marítimo logra una solución equitativo
el tribunal de la haya e intentó
solventar el conflicto concediendo una
pequeña parte de las aguas en disputa a
kenia y rechazando las reclamaciones de
somalia por daños y perjuicios pero eso
no fue suficiente para nairobi que ha
rechazado la decisión calificando al
tribunal de parcial la sentencia de la
cj es definitiva e inapelable pero el
tribunal no tiene medios para hacer
cumplir sus resoluciones no obstante los
estados pueden acudir al consejo de
seguridad de la onu si otro país no
acata un fallo